Okay. Welcome back to Gary’s Economics.
Today we are going to talk about
giving your money to the government.
All right.
So I wanted to do a quick one addressing
one of the most common questions, criticisms
we get on the channel,
which is why do you want to increase taxes?
All of that money is going to go to government.
Government is full of corrupt idiots.
They're going to steal my money.
They're going to waste my money. It's a waste of time.
Don't do it. Gary, you're a communist.
And
I thought this was an interesting one to talk about.
Because there's a kind of a perception
when I say that I want to tax
the rich more, that I must
necessarily be wanting
to give more money to the government.
I must be wanting to increase the size of government.
And I think this is
a good chance basically to show that
this is not what I'm trying to do.
So when I talk about taxing the rich,
first thing to say is I'm talking
about taxing the very rich.
This is not about taxing,
very likely, not about taxing you, not about your kids.
It's not about taxing lawyers
or even bankers or people
who are making sort of 100, 200 grand a year.
We're talking about taxing
extremely wealthy individuals
with wealth of more than £10 million.
And what we want to do is to tax them
so that we can lower your taxes.
This is not really by increasing
the size of government at all.
What I see is a situation
where ordinary families
are increasingly losing their wealth,
and that wealth is flowing
to the very, very rich.
And I'm trying to see
how is it that we can, number one,
protect your family from losing its wealth?
And number two, help your family get its wealth back?
And I think this is,
it's an interesting thing to talk about,
because what is happening
here is quite counterintuitive.
And when I say
we want to tax
the rich, people think immediately more taxation means,
more taxation for me,
less money for me, less money
and wealth for me and my family.
And instead that money and wealth
go into the government.
And people think that Gary's a big government guy.
Gary is a communist.
But really what this is about
is, is about getting your wealth back.
And I think that's quite a,
it's an interesting concept, right,
that we can increase tax
and then increasing in tax,
we can get your wealth back.
So I wanted to just go through
the basic
logic of how
it can be
that increasing tax can make you richer,
because that is ultimately what I'm trying to do here.
Assuming that you are not a super rich person
and you are from an ordinary family.
I want to increase tax to make you richer
and your family, you as an individual.
So how does this work?
The first
and most obvious way is,
if we increase taxation on the super rich,
we can reduce your taxes.
So at the moment we have a tax system
which taxes working people at a very high rate.
You know, I worked
and I made quite a lot of money
and I was paying more than 50% tax at the time.
But it taxes, extremely wealthy families,
extremely wealthy individuals at a rate
often close to 0%.
These guys have an enormous amount of wealth.
They generate enormous amount of income
from that wealth.
They don't pay tax.
If we tax them much more, we can reduce your taxes.
This means more money in your pocket.
This means more money going to you.
Now, I'm not instinctively a big government person,
but we do exist at the moment in this country,
the UK, at the end of 50 years of austerity,
which has really starved
a lot of government services of money,
especially if you look at things like
local government services,
even things like the police, education,
massively starved of money,
things like
the legal system,
the court system, anyone who works
anywhere, especially in local services,
will see massive starvation of money.
So I think at this point
you probably would want to use some of that money
to help fund local services, which are being...
have been decimated the last 15, 20 years.
What this means is
less money for the rich, more money for you
because your taxes are reduced,
more money for local services,
so you won't have to pay for things
which you're currently paying for,
because that would be provided by the government.
You have more money in your pocket.
Local workers around
you will have more money in their pocket
because
government are trying to hire staff,
trying to improve the public services
which have been decimated for a long time.
It means you’ll have more money.
People around you will have more money.
You will be able to spend that money.
People around
you will be able to spend that money,
which means your wages will go up.
So we say, number one, your wages go up.
Number two, your taxes go down.
And that means more wealth in your pocket.
Now there is another channel
by which increasing taxation on the rich
will make you richer.
I think this is also quite
interesting and counterintuitive,
which is if you increase tax
on the very rich people with wealths of £10 million,
£100 million, a billion massively,
you will enforce rich people selling their assets.
If you tax them really, really highly
and to be honest, I think at this point
wealth inequality has become so
large and is growing so quickly.
You really do need to tax
these people really massively.
If you where to tax them a lot,
you could put them in a situation
where they have to sell their assets.
And I think a lot of people
see this instinctively as a bad thing.
It's often an argument that is made.
You shouldn't tax the rich a lot
because maybe they're not that cash rich.
Maybe they're just holding lots of assets.
And if you tax them a lot
they’ll have to sell their assets.
Increasingly, as wealth inequality grows
a bigger and bigger share of the national wealth
of national assets are owned by the very rich.
Now, if you are very rich, say
you have a wealth of £100 million or let's say
£500 million, like Rishi Sunak,
according to the Sunday Times,
you would generate a passive income of £25 million
a year,
£2 million a month.
If the wealth is being held
by people who have a passive income of £2 million
per month,
they will never sell anything.
If you had a large amount of wealth,
you're making £2 million a month.
Why would you ever sell any of your assets?
You're making £2 million a month.
You never need to sell anything.
So increasingly,
we are in a situation where the assets are owned
by people who never have to sell any assets.
If that is the situation,
obviously, working people like you,
like your kids, like a parent
will never be able to afford assets.
If you want working people
to be able to afford assets like housing,
it is essential that the current owners of assets
at some point sell their assets.
If you give all the assets
to people
that never sell assets,
it will be impossible
for working people without assets to buy assets.
This is how things work.
It's impossible to buy a thing if nobody said a thing.
It is vital in order to get things
like housing back
into the hands of ordinary working families,
that the owners of assets sell their assets.
At the moment,
the superrich have enormous passive incomes,
they never sell anything.
We need them to sell their assets.
So for me,
taxing the super rich is not about growing government.
It's definitely not about moving us
to a communist state.
Taxing the rich is about rebalancing
essentially power and ownership in our society.
At the moment,
both government
and the middle class are losing
their wealth rapidly to the rich.
The only way to get that back is through taxation.
If we tax them more, we can tax you less.
You'll have more money.
The rich will be selling assets.
That means you and your kids can have assets.
You can own things. You can be rich.
We're not going to get assets
into the hands of ordinary working people
unless we take them out of the hands
of the people who own everything.
And the only way to do that is through taxation.
So for me,
taxation is about growing the assets
and the wealth of ordinary working people.
And I would like to sort of
get you to see taxation in a new light.
Taxation has been given a terrible brand,
largely by rich people,
because they don't want to pay it.
Taxation is how you define yourself.
Taxation is how you get wealth back from the group
that is taking your wealth.
And I kind of want increasingly, for you
to see taxation as kind of a tool you can use
in essentially a war.
Now, when you have a war,
when you have an invading army,
why do people invade countries?
Why do people start wars?
Because they want to take the assets.
And what is happening in your country?
Assets that used to be owned by the middle class,
that used to be owned
by the government
are, over time, being owned by the rich
and the super rich.
That is what war is. War is about taking assets.
Your assets will not be owned by your kids
or grandkids.
They'll be owned by the kids
and the grandkids of the superrich.
They are an invading army.
The only tool you have to defend yourself is taxation.
So if you tax the rich,
we can get money in your pocket.
We can get assets, to your kids and your grandkids.
If you don't tax
the rich, inequality will grow more and more
and your grandkids will be poor.
So taxation for the rich is about reducing your taxes.
It's not about growing the state.
It's about protecting your kids from poverty.
The government not going to do it.
They're full of extremely wealthy people.
You have to fight back.
You have to use the only tool that you have,
which is taxation.
It's the only way to protect yourself from the rich.
We're going to keep campaigning for it.
Please share the videos. Help us grow this message.
Thank you.